after seeing alien covenant you probably
have some questions that's okay like
Prometheus before an alien covenant was
long on terror and short on answers as
such we're here to do our best to get to
the bottom of some of these mysteries
and try to figure out just what the
takeaway is for Ridley Scott's latest
extra-terrestrial murder fest so now
with the very obvious spoiler warning
let's try to explain the ending of alien
covenant why did David help Daniels and
Tennessee if you're a surprise when the
synthetic at the end of the movie turned
out to be the evil British David and not
the kind bland Walters and you haven't
seen a lot of movies have you the minute
you see Michael Fassbender playing two
robots one good one evil you have to
know that the bad ones gonna pull the
old Dipsy doodle on our heroes by the
end of the movie it's basically movie
law however even if the David reveal was
somewhat predictable it does raise the
question why did David help Daniels in
Tennessee during the final showdown with
the xenomorph it's not completely clear
but it seems likely that David suffered
from a planet-sized case of hubris his
whole plan seems to center around
finding ways to make the xenomorph
better through experimentation we got a
glimpse of some of his trials and errors
when we saw his lab along with what
remained of Elizabeth Shaw from
Prometheus it's possible that the final
showdown aboard the Covenant was for
David a test to see whether this version
of the xenomorph could get the better of
Daniels in Tennessee it failed so he's
got plans for bigger badder aliens when
the ship finally arrives at aura j6 on
the other hand maybe he simply saw
something in Daniels that he wanted to
preserve again so he could use her in
his future experiments whose mommy
at one point David says that his alien
pals are waiting for mother there are
plenty of ways to interpret this line a
pretty obvious reading is that the alien
eggs and more specifically the
facehuggers within need a host to do the
bloody and nasty with in essence anyone
who provides an incubation chamber for a
xenomorph is mother but what if there's
more to it than that
Prometheus and alien covenant are
prequels to the original alien franchise
and that includes aliens which was
written and directed by James Cameron in
that movie we learned the source of all
those lovely alien eggs the alien queen
since we didn't get to see anything
resembling a xenomorph Queen before
the engineers planet it's likely that it
hasn't been created yet David can't stay
up forever making new eggs so the
Queen's creation has to be on David's
agenda and that may spell a pretty bad
morning for our hero Daniel's when she
wakes up what did it all mean it may be
tough to decipher but it sure seems like
Ridley Scott was trying to tell us
something with this tale of space
colonization gone horribly awry well
let's think about this Daniel's and her
poor dead husband Jacob came aboard the
Covenant with hopes of starting a new
life on a new planet just because it's
an adventure
meanwhile for dead captain christopher
decided to stop on the engineers planet
in response to the weird communication
they picked up and to see if this new
world might be even better than the one
they've been going towards already and
daven decided that he should play God
and out create his creators what was the
result of all these decisions chaos
destruction and death more than anything
alien covenant is about the dangers of
unchecked human ambition if Daniels and
her fella had just seen on earth and
rented a nice apartment somewhere he
probably wouldn't have been burnt to a
crisp and a high person pod and if
Christopher hadn't diverted away from
orange a six well then we'd have a movie
about the dangers of micromanaging a
group of drunks spaceship workers but
there probably would have been far fewer
blood bars and body bursts and if David
hadn't decided to go full-on
supervillain well then he wouldn't have
inadvertently became that which he
despised what happens next two months
before alien covenants May 2017 release
the Sydney Morning Herald reported on a
set visit with director Ridley Scott in
that article Scott revealed that he's
already got the next movie in the
prequel series written and ready to go
that means that the dangling plot
threads of what will happen when the
Covenant arrives at or j6 will be
answered in whatever treatment Scott's
got locked in his desk drawer presumably
we'll see a whole mess of Xenomorphs
bursting out of colonists not to mention
a final showdown with David and Daniel's
or whoever else signs on for a sequel if
in win 20th century box announces it's
happening what happens when the prequels
are over not only as Scott got the
sequel to Covenant ready to go The
Hollywood Reporter said that Scott's
revealed plans to make yet another movie
in this prequel series that fourth movie
would apparently link up with the events
of the first
movie from 1979 and then no more alien
movies ever right well the entire reason
we're talking about new alien movies
right now at all is that franchises tend
to go for as long as people can earn
money from them whatever your opinion on
the current crop of alien flicks making
new movies in a recognizable series of
movies is a sure way to earn cash so
even though these prequels will have to
lead into the original movies somehow
there will likely be some effort to keep
the brand alive that means sequels that
pick up after the events of Alien
Resurrection or god help us alien vs.
predator it might also mean that we're
only a few short years away from alien
reboot don't say it can never happen
Hollywood rebooted Robocop Spider Man
Evil Dead and plenty more there's no
reason that alien won't be reborn soon
enough to after all getting born and
reborn is kind of what aliens do thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]